[Müzik]
herkese Merhaba benim ismim Umur Ali
Birant e Yaklaşık 3 bu5 4 yıldan beri 32
Günü sunuyorum size bir yol hikayesi
anlatmak
istiyorum bu yolda benim yaşadıklarımı
benim öğrendiklerimi ve de aynı zamanda
bu hayalet mülteciler dediğimiz
insanların yaşadıklarını anlatmak
istiyorum
şimdi 32 Günü sunmaya başladığımda en
büyük hayalim Hala da öyle tarihe
tanıklık etmek yani Düşünsenize
yanınızdan böyle bir tarih geçiyor ve de
siz onu kendi gözlerinizle
görebiliyorsunuz dokunabiliyorsan o paha
biçilmez bir duygu inanılmaz bir duygu O
son 3 yıldan beri 32 Gün programında
aşağı yukarı 10 saat mültecilerle ilgili
yayın yaptık işte Suriye'deki sınır kamp
gittik Eee Yunanistan'a gittik Makedonya
Sırbistan Yunan adalarına gittik İzmir
İstanbul Fransa'da Kale kampına bile
gittik ve de hep oradan Aynı cümleleri
duymaya başladım ben hep soruyordum
onlara ya dedim nedir Ne yapıyorsunuz
yani Niye gidiyorsunuz
insan
bu inanılmaz yolculuğu niye yapar hep
aynı cümleleri aldım
onlardan Ölmek var Allah'ın
takdiri dönmek
yok Ölmek var Allah'ın takdiri Dönmek
Yok anlamadım Tabii ki sonra herkese
aynı soruyu sordum ya Niye bir anda
böyle bu yolculuğa karar nedir o o
mekanizma Nasıl başlıyor çok basit silah
sesleri duyuluyor bir gün komşunuz da
mahallenizde köyünüzde sonra Elektrikler
kesiliyor Sonra sular kesiliyor sonra
bir gün otorite kayboluyor otorite
gidince
komşularla baş başa kalıyorsunuz iç
hesaplaşmalar
başlıyor bazen tabiat sizi itiyor Bazen
en basit şey o karara verdiriyor size o
da evinize geliyorsunuz çocuklar aç
yapacak hiçbir şeyiniz
yok orada bir anda o hayat değişikliğine
bir anda orada karar veriyorlar Ben
hayatımı değiştirmem gerekiyor Ben da
bir yere gitmem gerekiyor
diye Şimdi yolculuk nasıl başlıyor
biliyor musunuz bu 2015 yılında büyük
göç
başladı okuyorduk öyle 10 mülteciyi
geçti 500 mülteciyi geçti 1000 kişi
şurada 10.000 kişi şurada yakalandı
falan filan diye onları duymaya başladık
Ama esas nerede başlıyor biliyor musunuz
o Ege Sahillerinde başlıyor şimdi
gözlerinizi bir Kapatın bir kamyona
bindiriyorlar sizi 40 50 kişi bir koya
geliyorsunuz o koyda bir anda bekle
diyorlar size size bir numara veriyorlar
1 2 3 4 5 aradan bir ik saat içerisinde
bir kamyon geliyor kamyon İçinden bir
bot çıkıyor bir numara buraya diyorlar
hop aileler bölünüyor o şey yok abi ben
sen git ben sonra gelirim sen git sonra
ailemle ona biniyorsunuz son paranızı
vermişsiniz zaten paranız bile yok
hiçbir şeyiniz yok vermişsiniz 800 Euro
600 Euro iyi motorlar da 000 euroya
gidiyor sonra sizi itiyorlar diyorlar ki
ah avrup
işte uzakta görüyorsunuz oradaki ışığı
hissedebiliyorsunuz o Umut o nefes
alabileceğiniz yeri görebiliyorsunuz
orada o ışıkları görebiliyorsunuz hava
karanlık deniz sesi var sadece bir
motorun sesi belki yanınızdakiler dua
ağlıyor Belki o korkuyu düşünmenizi
istiyorum ve de Hep aynı
cümle Ölmek var Allah'ın takdiri dönm
yok Ben de arkadaşım ve kameramanım
Üzeyir yanar La birlikte
Eee Selanik'ten Makedonya'ya bu
yolculuğu yaptık Pardon
Macaristan'a Macaristan'a kadar bu
yolculuğu yaptık aşağı yukarı 1400
kilometrelik bir yoldu korkunç bir
yoldu ve de onlarla yürüdük
onlar ismi olmayan insanlar
rakamlar 2 milyon kişi yürüdü O yoldan o
2 milyon kişiden iki tanesi benim
hayatımı çok değiştirdi 2 milyon kişinin
yürüdüğü yoldan yürümek kadar korkunç
bir his
olamaz O 2 milyon kişiden bir
tanesi Sırbistan Macaristan sınırında
Nur fadli diye bir adamla tanıştım genç
ne iş yapıyorsun Şefim
dedi İtalyan yemekleri
yapıyormuş iki
arkadaşı çocuk ve eşiyle dolaşmış iki
kere batmış Ege denizinde İkisinde de
kurtulmuş dedim ki bana şey yap dedim
bir yemek yapsana bana dedim Şöyle
gözlerini kapattı Bir orkestra şefi
gibi mutfağında Kendini bir anda
mutfağında hayal et şimdi bir düşünün bu
40 derece
hava su yok hiçbir şey yok toprakta
oturuyorsunuz şöyle bir gözlerini
kapattı O da tenceresini koydu tuzunu
koydu makarna
korkunç bir manzaraydı şimdi bu bir
rakkam değil Bu bir insan sizin gibi bir
kişi size de
benziyor Kusura bakmayın hikaye her
sefer gelince gene şey yapıyor beni hep
her seferinde etkiliyor çok özür
dilerim ve de onlarla birlikte bu yolu
yaptık şimdi mülteci yolu diye bir
kavram var çok ilginç bir kavram o yolu
yaptığımızda 1400 km yaptığımız Tabii ki
yürüyerek yapmadık Yani yapsaydık bu
halde olmazdım yani 1400 km Ama onların
araçlarıyla
gittik yürüyorsunuz bazen bir 40
kilometre yürüyorsunuz bazen 20 kilmetre
otobüslere bindiriyorlar sizi hepsi
paralı Bunlar bedava değil bu işler yi
parası olmayanlar
yürüyor Biz de onlarla birlikte Bir
Mülteci yolu diye bir yol var Bu yolu
Siz görmüyorsunuz Çünkü siz mültecileri
görmeniz imkansız ondan onlara Ben
hayalet mülteciler diyorum Çünkü onlar
her sefer inde ana yoldan
yürümüyor bir patikadan yürüyorlar
paralel Ana yola onları Siz
kamplarda görebilirsiniz şansınız
varsa
onlar çadırlarda yatıyorlar
Onlar hiç sesleri
yok Biraz romantik gelebilecek ama 32
Günü yaparken şeyim oydu benim hep o
sesi
olmayanları n sesini duyabilmektir benim
hayalim Hala da öyle yani hep hayalim
geçmiş zaman diye konuşuyorum kusura
bakmayın ama işte mülteci yolu diye bir
yol var bu mülteci yolu çok ilginç bir
yol hemen anlıyorsunuz mültecilerin
buradan
geçtiğini Çünkü genellikle işte çocuk
bezleri su
şişeleri
battaniyeler
çadırlarla
dolu ve de biz O yoldan yürüdük onlarla
birlikte o
yol o kadar zor bir yol ki o kadar
ilginç bir yol ki Çünkü o yolda Siz
kaosu görebiliyorsunuz o Hayatın en
düşük noktasını görebiliyorsunuz Bir
insanın bir babanın iki tane
çocuğuyla nereye gittiğini bilmediği
dilini bilmediği bir ülkede buluyorsunuz
kendinizi bir düşünün O insanı Bir
düşünmek gerekiyor orada bir
anda biz de onları düşünerek He bu yolu
yaptık hiçbir zaman susadım demedik 6
gün sürdü Bu Yol bir kere bile susadım
demedik ayıp yoruldum İmkansız ama
onlarla birlikte bu yolu yaptık ve de
iyi ki de yaptım Çünkü hayatımı
değiştirdi benim benim bakış açımı
değiştirdi şimdi bu ik Dünya Savaşı'ndan
sonra en büyük insanlık dramını tanıklık
ettim o yold da İnsanlığın en kötü
halini gördüm sadece ya allah demeyi
bilen Makedon polisi elinde bir sopayla
sanki böyle şey yapıyormuş gibi ne
yapsın insan ama insanoğlunu da gördüm
insanlığı da gördüm orada o insanlığın
vermiş olduğu o güzelliği de gördüm Biz
susayınca bir dede bize yaklaştı ve de
bizi zorla su içir ya torununu gördü
bizde ya da kendini gördü gençliğini
gördü
orada Biz oturunca yanımıza gelip
bir şey var mı diye soranlar oldu bir
şey var mı Biz nasıl böyle bir şey nasıl
bize sorarlar cebimizde para var her
şeyimiz var Onların hiçbir şeyleri yok
ve de her seferinde Onlara sordum Hep
gelenlere ne var çantanda hep açıyorlar
seve seve açıyorlardı hiç utanma duygusu
diye bir şey yok Nasıl olabilir ki
hiçbir şeyi yok artık adamın o çantanın
içinde genellikle ne biraz yemek işte
biraz bir kağıt bir tshirt I love samos
I love işte Bodrum Bir
forma Bu
insanlarla
yürüdük ve de çantanın içinden hep bir
kimlik böyle plastiğe sarılmış bir
evvelki hayatlarıyla bağı olan tek şey
oydu O kimlik ve de plastiği iyice
sarılmış ıslanmasın diye Paran var mı
Yok var 5 10 Euro her zaman var bir sim
kart bu mal var lıkla sokağa çıktılar bu
insanlar bu yolu
yaptılar
mülteciler hayalet mülteciler Çünkü siz
görmüyorsunuz
onları onlar hep yan yollardan
dolaşıyor en son yolculuğumuzda
Makedonya'dan Pardon sırbistan'dan
Macaristan'a geçiyorduk bir 15 kilomet
bir tren
yolu o en son Tren yolunda giderken Eee
yavaş yavaş sınıra yaklaştığımızda
uzaktan Avrupa'nın duvarlarının
örüldüğünü gördük yavaş yavaş Böyle
yaklaştığını Gördük Bir 15 kilometrelik
bir yol Uzun Bir Yol yağmurun altında
şeyde hava soğuk bir anda soğudu hava
tabii biz Selanik'ten Macaristan'a
gittiğimizde kıyafetlerimiz de şeydi ama
üşümedi bir hakkımız yok
bizim terlik ve şortla gelen
var Niye gidiyor amacı ne daha iyi bir
yaşam daha iyi bir gelecek o kadar
değerli bir şey ki o O adam onu
söylediği zaman niye gidiyorsun benim
için hayatım için
diyor kim onu durdurabilir ki Çünkü o
Fikri koymuş kafasına ben
gideceğim ben oğlum için kızım için
ailem için ben bunu
yapacağım Macaristan'a geçtik gayet
güzel bir hava tren istasyonuna vardık
dedik ki Tamam son gün çekim bu iş
bitiyor Üzeyir le 6 gün çekim yapmışız
gibiyiz Yani bir kere duş almışız
iki kere bizi tutuklamaya çalıştılar Bu
arada bizi göçmen zannettiler resmen Ama
Allah'tan cebimizden kimlikler mimikler
çıkınca rahat
bıraktılar akşam bir yemek yedik
Budapeşte ilginç bir yer kuzeyindedir
şey tren istasyonu Güney isi biraz daha
turistik güneyde turistler dolaşıyor
dükkanlar insanlar keyfi çok yerinde
kuzeyinde de tren istasyonu bütün
mültecilerle dolu ve de aynı adamlarla
karşılaştık o ilk gün Yunanistan'daki
kampı geçerken tanıştığım adamlarla
karşılaştım yemeğimizi yedik akşam geri
dönüyoruz tam dönerken dedim ki ya bir
son bir tur daha
atalım bakalım belki bir hikaye
çıkar o tünellerin arasında böyle bir
ışık şei var ışık var böyle
ışıklandırılmış böyle bir yer var oradan
bir tel
indirilmiş orada telefonlar şarj
ediliyor
Orada ikinci kişiyle tanıştım Kerküklü
Ahmet Selamünaleyküm Aleykümselam hemen
Türkçe konuşuluyor Zaten size birebir
söyleyeceğim size ne şey
olduğunu dedim Ne
yapıyorsun dedim Çocuğun var
mı 5 yaşında oğlum var dedi benim de
oğlum
var dedi
ki bomba
patladı yarı adamım
gitti Ben
korkmadım ölümden korksam gelmeyeceğim
dedi ben o suyu
geçtim
ölmedim Allah ölmemi istemedi
dedi Ölmek var dedi Allah'ın takdiri
dönmek yok
dedi O
saniye o
an Budapeşte tren istasyonunun
tünellerinde bütün o
rakamlar bütün o
insanlar bütün o
datalar hepsi birer birey oldu o anda
hepsinin bir hikayesi olduğunu dank etti
hepsi birer
insan bu kadar
zor bir şey ki bunu
Kabullenmek ve de O insandan şu çıktı
benim için bunlar mülteci falan filan
değil
kardeşim bunlar
insanoğlunun kahramanları benim için
benim yol Hikayem bu çok teşekkür
[Müzik]
ederim